we begin this morning with ramped up
efforts in washington to help alleviate
the baby formula shortage gripping much
of the nation the house is set to
consider a measure to buy excess
supplies of formula in other countries
as a way to ease the struggle that so
many american families are facing in a
video released by the white house last
night president biden urged u.s
manufacturers to increase production and
he talked to retailers about ways to
better restock their shelves mr biden
also said formula formula maker abbott
laboratories is issuing rebates to give
women infants and children in the food
stamps program the flexibility to buy
alternative products even other brands
of formula it comes as 43 percent of
store shelves across the country are out
of formula elise preston is here with
the story elise good morning michelle
good morning while millions of
frustrated parents wait for domestic and
imported formula to hit store shelves
they're getting creative in their
searches to feed their babies i spoke to
a mother who experienced this pain
firsthand
red blotches cover nine-month-old
reign's body an allergic reaction after
his mom was forced to feed him a
different kind of formula miranda cherry
says the ongoing shortage is to blame
for her baby boy getting sick prompting
the north carolina mom to drive an hour
to a children's hospital emergency room
his hands and his feet were turning blue
from the swelling
and it was pitiful so then we took him
four different doctors it's been more
than a week since those initial doctors
visits and cherry is still scrambling to
find reasonably priced formula to feed
her young son does it anger you that
you're trying to feed your baby he's
allergic to every other formula that
you've given him and people are price
gouging that they're taking advantage of
this absolutely it makes me furious
i shouldn't have to
pay triple or quadruple the price of
something just to feed my child across
the country families are desperate to
get formula for their hungry and
helpless babies but it could be weeks
before families see relief on store
shelves this is a process we're working
on it very very hard there's nothing
more urgent we're working on than that
right now urgent after ongoing supply
chain problems weakened the nation stock
months ago and then abbott nutrition
recalled three types of infant formula
after two babies died from bacterial
infections the company shut down its
largest plant in michigan it's been very
difficult
very
it's like a scavenger hunt every week
helping to ease the burden breast milk
banks this one in new york says it's
seen an increase in moms donating their
extra supply and families coming in for
help it's absolutely heartbreaking i
mean as as a mother myself
as you know watching these mothers go
through this it is absolutely
heartbreaking and we are doing our best
to really help relieve that stress but
not all babies can drink breast milk so
for now cherry says rain is living off
samples from his pediatrician's office
how long does it take for rain to go
through a can of formula
two three days if i'm lucky
now cherry fears as so many families are
needed won't be long before
pediatricians offices are tapped out too
to help families who are struggling to
find milk the department of health and
human services has launched a website
connecting parents to resources you can
see it on your screen it's
hhs.gov backslash formula
and in this case
some of these babies just can't take
breast milk it's not that simple yeah
it's so heartbreaking when you're
looking on social media and moms are
sharing their families they're saying
that for whatever reason their babies
can't digest the milk or they've just
been allergic since day one right and
it's a shame to see some people shaming
moms who are not breastfeeding no matter
the reason yeah that's not what this is
about it's trying to help each other
through it yeah and moms are speaking
out about that too they're just
frustrated they're saying listen if you
have a can of formula you can help me
out please do so right other than that i
have so much stress going on as is
hopefully help on the way very soon at
least thank you very much